last week our great guest host who
filled in for me did a great job
covering the plea agreement that Hunter
Biden has reached with the justice
department I don't really have much to
add other than my position has always
been if there's evidence that Hunter
Biden did anything wrong investigate him
if it points to charges charge them and
then either try him or strike a plea
deal do don't do anything special for
the guy because he is the son of
President Joe Biden okay so that
happened and uh now the right is
starting to cook up all sorts of
additional conspiracy theories of course
many on the right are saying well he was
able he was allowed to get a plea deal
that avoids prison time because he's the
son of Joe Biden there's no evidence of
that the evidence is that
um uh his his plea deal was very much in
line with what many would see if they
are represented by competent counsel in
such a situation so that line isn't
going very well for the right so the new
one is this is just so so amazing over
the weekend as uh attention went to this
failed coup attempt in Russia which we
talked about at the top of the show over
on Fox News Maria barter Romo yesterday
came up with the conspiracy theory
that the entire coup attempt
might have been fabricated to take
attention away from Hunter Biden if you
can believe that now you might say David
that doesn't make any sense there's no
evidence for that
of course of course but we're operating
or they are operating in a different
world listen to this
oh
we have a glitched clip I'm glitching
almost as badly As Trump hold on here we
go so does it break through and become a
real problem the White House wanted to
give the media something else to cover
and this is the mo this is exactly the
way they do things in fact the White
House wanted to give the media something
else to cover okay Friday I said wow
what a blockbuster what's that message
I'm sure there will be an enormous story
over the weekend that the White House is
going to be pushing to take this story
off of the front page and sure enough
we've got the state department drumming
up all the drama that took place over
the weekend in Russia so I don't know if
it's going to break through the
mainstream media has an excuse again not
to cover it they're covering everything
about Russia and the Wagner group yeah
it's true as if it really matters to the
US right now yeah by the way you
mentioned
um
as if it matters to the U.S whether the
authoritarian leader of one of the three
Global superpowers of which the U.S is
one as if it matters whether they are
deposed in a coup and it doesn't really
matter and it's distracting from the
hunter Biden story what on Earth is
wrong with these people and it's
important to remember that according to
them
the first Trump arrest was meant to
distract from something and now I
actually don't remember I don't remember
if it was inflation does anybody in the
audience remember what the first Trump
arrest was meant to distract from was it
something about Biden
Biden tripping or something like that
anyway the first Trump arrest was meant
to be a distraction from that the second
Trump arrest was meant to be a
distraction from the explosive claims of
a whistleblower about Joe Biden a
whistleblower they can't find uh whose
recordings may not exist look that was
that was the second the reason for the
second Trump arrest and then now the
entire Russian coup attempt is to
distract from Hunter Biden a potential
coup that would destabilize an
adversarial superpower that also happens
to have gobs of nuclear weapons not
really a story what matters much more is
Hunter Biden using drugs and his
WhatsApp text messages or something like
that
um once again the details Hunter Biden
has pleaded guilty or will plead guilty
to two tax misdemeanors and he struck a
deal to also resolve a gun charge
according to the justice department he
failed to pay at least 100K in taxes in
2017 and 2018 by their deadlines he has
since fully repaid those taxes as well
as the fines and he unlawfully possessed
a gun for 11 days in 2018 he knew he
wasn't supposed to have a gun and uh
that that's what happened so he has
struck a deal and the good news is that
now that we see that Hunter Biden did
have to face consequences we can all
rest easy knowing that it's not only
Trump who is going to have to uh be
adjudicated for the things he allegedly
did right are we ready to say that the
two-tier justice system of Republicans
and Democrats isn't actually a thing no
we're not because the new argument is
Hunter got a sweetheart deal
because he's a Democrat and the son of
Joe Biden this is a reminder I told you
guys this a year ago
if they ever do go after Hunter Biden
the right isn't going to let up they
will simply say he wasn't charged
seriously enough
or he was given a light sentence or a
slap on the wrist or whatever because of
Joe Biden and that is exactly what they
are now saying
30 million trees are destroyed every
year for toilet paper in the U.S alone
so toilet paper is a big contributor to
deforestation and climate change our
sponsor real paper makes toilet paper
from bamboo bamboo plants keep growing
which means no deforestation bamboo also
absorbs five times as much carbon from
the atmosphere as pine trees and bamboo
toilet paper is stronger than regular
toilet paper and even softer so bamboo
toilet paper is all around a win for you
and for the environment it's time to
move on from that toilet paper from
trees that you're using at home when you
use real paper it doesn't feel like
you're sacrificing anything it's soft
and fluffy and they'll ship it to your
door in plastic free packaging on a
schedule super easy with every box of
real paper you buy they are funding
reforestation efforts across the country
through their partnership with one tree
planted so unlike the toilet paper that
cuts down trees real is helping to
actively plant them go to realpaper.com
Pacman and use code Pacman for 30 off
your first order and free shipping the
link is down below